it's time for drew's news your daily
shot of good news wheatgrass straight
down the gullet
and with me at the desk is my favorite
co-pilot rusty ross matthews hi
everybody hi
hi and today we are joined by a
fantastic guest he is the best-selling
author of think like a monk
and now he's the chief purpose officer
at calm the app that helps us all be a
little more mindful what a success
that's become love
thank goodness watch this
the daily j is seven mindful minutes
we're going to talk about purpose values
meaning habits and goals relationships
communication we're going to learn how
to master our minds
the only jay shetty
i love listening to you've got such a a
soothing voice i don't know about a
soothing voice i wish i had one but you
you you have that thing that makes us
take a moment and thinking if people are
watching this right now and they think
okay i want to start
my personal journey of wellness what's
something they can do today
okay so i'm going to give you something
for your body
something for your mind and something
for your heart okay so for your body i
want everyone to just get their 10 000
steps in per day it's simple it is
simpler than you think take a walk move
around it's so powerful and so simple
for your mind meditation may sound scary
it may sound intimidating it's a bit
challenging but if you can just take
seven minutes every single day to
meditate to just schedule time with
yourself no distractions just to be
present with yourself and then for your
heart share gratitude with someone if
you can thank someone for something that
they've done for you today
someone that maybe you even forgotten
about someone probably from your past
who did something really small but led
to this big impact in your life if you
remember them i promise you you're going
to walk away feeling phenomenal so that
would be the three things we can do that
[Music]
you